[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi avec un focus sur les
métiers du commerce et de la vente
comment se former mais aussi quelles
sont les entreprises qui recrutent
sans plus tarder voici le sommaire les
métiers dans cette filière sont nombreux
illustration avec le commerce de
proximité bioko plein champ et le
magasin de prêt-à-porter christine laure
à l'espace saint quentin apprendre à
devenir un bon vendeur c'est ce que
proposent les nce upac guyancourt
l'immersion dans cette école supérieure
de l'entreprise et du management
enfin si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises qui recrutent
c'est un secteur qui ne connaît pas la
crise et qui est en perpétuelle
évolution
les métiers du commerce et de la vente
offre de nombreuses opportunités en
france y compris à saint quentin en
yvelines et des professions aux
multiples facettes comme vous allez
pouvoir le voir à travers ce reportage
avec ses douze mille mètres carrés
ces deux drives et ses 480
collaborateurs hypermarchés auchan à
maurepas embauche des hôtesses de caisse
des employés commerciaux ou encore des
managers de rayon des profils très
différents que l'on retrouve également
dans des plus petites enseignes nous
sommes à biocoop plein champ dans la
ville à montigny le bretonneux leader en
france de la distribution alimentaire
biologique l'ancien propos sur 300
mètres carrés des produits issus du
commerce équitable
[Musique]
bonjour sandrine vanhoutte la
responsable des produits frais dans ce
magasin alors ça consiste en quoi
mais en fait ça consiste tout simplement
à faire des communs
ensuite réapprovisionner les rayons et
surtout d'idées
les clients par rapport
aux produits bio que l'on bon il
pourrait être responsable de produits
frais dans un magasin il faut avoir quoi
comme diplôme moi là bas j'ai un dut en
techniques de commercialisation
mais je suis rentré en fait dans le
magasin par la petite porte en
commençant par la caisse
j'ai fait différent réunion au fur et à
mesure et puis jusqu'à me retrouver en
fait responsable des produits frais
renato modiano bonjour vous êtes le
responsable de ce magasin c'est quoi
vraiment votre votre rôle alors bon
comme tout responsable de magasin ou
donc deux entreprises vont c'est le
management c'est la gestion
c'est également définir la stratégie du
magasin qui est celle de notre réseau
biocoop que je fais appliquer vie si
dans ma structure et veillez à ce que
l'échantillonnage de produits la
proposition soit conforme aux
prescriptions de la charte de biocoop
à l'espace saint quentin christine laure
fait partie de l'une des 150 boutiques
de la marque en france
un magasin à taille humaine qui
s'adresse exclusivement aux femmes
isabelle kong alves bonjour à manger ou
alors vous êtes la responsable de cette
boutique combien de salariés travaillent
ici
alain nous sommes cinq là une
responsable de magasin à moi même mon
adjointe et nous avons deux autres
vendeuses à 35 heures alors selon vous
quelles sont les qualités indispensables
pour retravailler dans un magasin de
prêt-à-porter puis plus particulièrement
dans cette boutique alors la première
c'est être à l'écouté de notre clientèle
ça c'est la première où on ne peut pas
passer outre sa ben le sourire l'accueil
un accueil chaleureux que la cliente se
sente comme chez elle dans un endroit
convivial
mélina bonjour bonjour vous êtes
vendeuse dans cette boutique quelles
sont vos missions quotidiennes mano
mission quotidienne ça va être de ranger
le magasin que les magasins sont propres
de mettre nos articles toujours à la
taille de voilà d'être accueillante au
niveau des clientes
mon conseiller au sénat demain les
clients conseiller les clientes
surtout par rapport à leur recherche des
besoins alors ça fait combien de temps
que vous faites ce métier je suis dans
la vente depuis l'âge de 15 ans et je
suis actuellement dans le magasin depuis
deux mois alors pour être vendeuse vous
avez fait quoi comme comme formation
alors moi j'ai été en bac pro commerce
voilà j'ai fait un début de bts muc qui
est la suite du bac pro commerce
que ce soit pour une enseigne qui
emploie plusieurs centaines de salariés
ou pour des commerces de proximité et
des boutiques de prêt-à-porter
l'équation est la même pour ces métiers
une bonne organisation de la
disponibilité et un bon relationnel
alors pour apprendre tous les rouages de
ces métiers il existe plusieurs types de
formation je vous propose de prendre la
direction de l'école supérieure de
l'entreprise et du management à
guyancourt
[Musique]
situé à proximité de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines l'école supérieure
de l'entreprise et du management
accueille chaque année encore plus de
300 étudiants
elle propose des formations initiale et
en alternance dans trois domaines
l'informatique la comptabilité gestion
ainsi que le commerce et la vente
il
[Musique]
du
jean b valait bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le directeur pédagogique de l'aisne
sucre vous êtes également en charge des
formations en commerce et marketing
alors qu'est ce qu'on apprend dans ces
filières alors on apprend beaucoup de
choses l'objectif étant de donner à nos
étudiants la possibilité d'intégrer des
équipes commerciales soit dans le
commerce soit dans le monde de
l'entreprise
alors quel est le contenu de ces de ces
formations alors il aborde pas tout ce
qui est lié à la vente bien évidemment
la vente aux particuliers ce qu'on
appelle le bitoux si la vente aux
professionnels le 'b to b' et la vente
en boutique
tout ce qui est lié au marketing au
management à la gestion les éléments
essentiels pour promettre un bon vendeur
alors il ya plusieurs niveaux puisque on
va retrouver des bts et puis la
nouveauté aussi cette année allen sup
c'est la création d'un bac +5 en fait
c'est tout à fait ça c'est quelque chose
de très important c'est dire que cette
école qui a quand même maintenant plus
de 28 ans avec plus de 350 étudiants
fait que nous avons la capacité de
prendre des étudiants aux sorties de
bach et de les emmener jusqu'au master
au travers bas bts de bachelor et du
masters
[Musique]
bonjour notre ami et les le cours que
vous êtes en train de suivre
on étudie le droit actuellement alors
vous êtes en bts 1 nrcc sa vie pourquoi
avoir choisi cette formation alors 2e
dans un premier temps parce que c'était
la continuité logique de mon
baccalauréat ès tmg et parce que voilà
j'ai vu qu'à filière vraiment me
correspondait le commerce c'est quelque
chose dans lequel j'ai toujours voulu
être
et voilà c'est vraiment un costume
éthologique j'apprécie des matières
qu'on étudie
[Musique]
tiffany bonjour vous êtes en hebdo
commerce et marketing
pourquoi vous avez choisi d'intégrer
cette formation alors j'ai fait toutes
mes études dans le commerce j'ai fait un
bts technico-commercial ensuite j'ai
fait un bachelor au sein de la nuque et
ensuite j'ai choisi de faire un m2
commerce et marketing puisque pour moi
j'aime la relation client je trouve que
le commerce est primordial
la fin de cette formation dont vous
aurez un bac + 5 vous voulez faire quoi
comme métier alors moi ce que j'aimerais
ya des spécialités dans ce masters et je
voudrais me spécialiser dans la grande
distribution pouvoir entrer dans une
centrale d'achat est justement bas
certes où la relation client dans dans
les attentes centrales d'achat de la
grande distribution
[Musique]
durant les trois dernières années le
pourcentage de réussite des bts muc nrc
a dépassé les 90% à l'est au sud à
l'issue de leur formation la quasi
totalité des étudiants ont trouvé un
premier emploi
voilà vous en savez désormais plus sur
les métiers du commerce et de la vente
alors si pourquoi pas vous avez envie de
vous lancer dans ce secteur
voici ce qu'il faut retenir pour être
vendeur ou vendeuse dans un magasin de
prêt-à-porter comme mélina il faut
penser ap commerce un bac pro commerce
ou bien un bts commerce
vos missions disposer les produits dans
les rayons ou encore faire attention à
l'étiquetage le salaire en début de
carrière l'équivalent du smic
l'évolution possible être responsable de
magasin et puis la qualité indispensable
avoir le sens du contact deuxième métier
dont il était question dans ce numéro de
mode d'emploi responsable d'un commerce
de proximité
les missions principales encadrer le
personnel et développer le chiffre
d'affaires du magasin
alors pour cela il faut un bts muc ou un
bachelor responsable du développement
commercial
la rémunération est en moyenne de 1600
euros nets en début de carhaix carrière
et selon la taille de l'entreprise
l'évolution possible directeur régional
et puis la qualité indispensable pour ce
métier être rigoureuse alors maintenant
si vous êtes à la recherche d'un emploi
et bien un conseil prenez de quoi noter
dans mode d'emploi vous le savez nous
donnons la parole aux chefs d'entreprise
aux biens ont chargé de recrutement de
notre région alors voyons tout de suite
et bien quelles sont les entreprises qui
recrutent
bonjour je suis cyril giovannini le
responsable de l'agencé kangourou kids
de saint quentin en yvelines
nous faisons de la garde d'enfants à
domicile sur la commune de saint quentin
actuellement nous proposons 25 postes de
garde d'enfants ou en sortie d'école ou
en sortie de crèches entre 5 et 25
heures par semaine
donc si jamais cela vous intéresse vous
pouvez nous contacter au 01 84 19 40 29
merci
je suis responsable sourcing et
communication rh chez pas le régime
phone régie nous sommes prestataires de
services nous recrutons des hôtes et des
hôtesses d'accueil d'entreprises que
nous positionnons chez nos clients afin
de gérer donc là que physique
accueil téléphonique et salles de
réunions commander un taxi par exemple
l'expérience sur nos métiers n'est pas
indispensable
nous recherchons avant tout des
personnes avec des qualités humaines
l'aisance relationnelle un savoir être
et un bon niveau d'anglais
actuellement 150 postes sont à pourvoir
si vous êtes intéressés par nos métiers
je vous invite à retrouver nos offres
sur notre site internet petit régis
prendre comme bonjour je suis renato
modiano le responsable du magasin
biocoop plein champ à saint quentin en
yvelines et nous avons un recrutement
actuellement pour un salarié
adjoint au responsable du rayon épicerie
sèche
si vous êtes intéressé contactez sylvain
à l'adresse plein champ tir et sylvain @
orange.fr merci beaucoup et bien sûr
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter à nous
envoyer vos offres de recrutement à
l'adresse qui s'affiche en bas de votre
écran rédaction @ tv soit 118 points
comme c'est bientôt la fin de ce mode
d'emploi mais avant va jeter un rapide
coup d'oeil aux événements qui vous
attendent
sachez que la police nationale organise
jeudi 28 septembre une opération de
recrutement pour devenir adjoint de
sécurité c'est de 8h à 18h et ça se
passe à la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines
si vous voulez plus d'informations un
numéro est à votre disposition
le 01 69 83 77 58 à la cité des métiers
attrape sachez qu'un forum santé et
emploi a lieu le lundi 2 octobre de 9h à
12h il est destiné aux salariés en arrêt
de travail
vous devez vous inscrire au 01 34 82 82
et puis jeudi 12 octobre à maurepas le
café de la plage accueille un service
civique dating de 14h à 18h30 c'est
destiné aux jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qui
souhaitent intégrer le service civique
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 12
octobre pour un nouveau mode d'emploi
consacré cette fois ci aux filières qui
recrutent à saint quentin en yvelines
à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]